gvt est notre avenir sauver la planète
maintenant les militants écologistes
sont descendus dans les rues d'allemagne
à 48 heures d'un scrutin qui doit
renouveler le parlement et surtout
déterminée qui succédera en guélat
merkel à la chancellerie à berlin la
figure de ce mouvement de la génération
climat et suédoises greta tanberg s'est
adressé à la foule devant le parlement
où ils siègeront dans le one pro qui
estime klaus
yes we made you move out
of
l'écologie a été l'un des thèmes
dominants de la campagne qui tire à sa
fin ce devait être un cadeau en or pour
le parti vert et ça gêne tête d'affiche
anna lena berlocq mais cette dernière
n'a pas su capitaliser sur un message au
diapason avec les inquiétudes des
électeurs est-ce que puis le niveau
mondial à nola en cours et est mort en
chute risikko abba d'escrocs cerisy
colza est 20e né sous toute ma carrière
est l'un de ces indécis il est venu
entendre la candidate a man ray
après seize ans dans gala merkel il n'a
pas envie d'une relation de passage pour
faire une transition qui est difficile
à lindau dans le sud ouest du pays
elisabeth roesch dorffer hésitent encore
et l'oci et les venues entendre armin
laschet tu le successeur d'angela merkel
à la tête du parti des chrétiens
démocrates espèrent une porte ma rue à
rennes et à malte définitive yao jian
c'est une accusation qui revient souvent
son endroit il manque deux principes
celui qui aurait dû bénéficier en partie
du moins de l'affection toujours
importantes qu'ont les allemands pour un
gala merkel malgré son bilan mitigé se
retrouve donc sur la défensive en cette
fin de campagne
son parti l'a bien compris dans le
dernier droit des rassemblements
politiques a fait appel aux meilleurs
arguments de vente qui termine la chaîne
à offrir la chancelière sortante we know
it could do et y est nous sommes
dans une campagne électorale qui est
loin d'avoir soulevé les passions ce
n'est finalement peut être pas une
surprise si le grand gagnant est
candidat sur lequel aucun des analystes
n'aurait misé en début de course
[Applaudissements]
la choletaise le candidat des
sociaux-démocrates et tantôt qualifié
d'ennuyeux tantôt d'automates pour sa
tendance à répondre aux questions comme
un robot
mais le ministre des finances et vice
chancelier actuelle est peut être
finalement celui qui offre aux allemands
le meilleur gage de stabilité lui se
décrit comme un moteur de changement i'm
so many people
of
the
night is si l'on en croit les sondages
olaf scholz et les sociaux démocrates
seront donc les grands vainqueurs ce
dimanche mais pour gouverner ils devront
nécessairement formé une alliance et sur
cette question le mystère plane toujours
les verts se voient déjà comme partie
prenante de cette coalition mais à
l'absurde sera-t-il le choix des
libéraux de droite ou plutôt
donnera-t-il coup de barre vers
l'extrême gauche le visage du prochain
gouvernement dépendra de ses choix ici
marie-eve bédard radio-canada colonnes